fresh development in the investigation
over the death of anti-corruption lawyer
Sergei Magnitsky nearly 10 years ago
Russian prosecutors are looking into
whether or not his killing was organized
by his former boss the british-based
financier William Broder acknowledged
biggest case material post-mortem tests
showed that there were symptoms of
chronic poisoning with the toxic
water-soluble aluminium compounds taken
orally there has never been full-scale
research of such substances in Russia
but over a dozens of years Texico
logical research of these compounds have
been conducted especially by the US
France and Italy we have to understand
who is mr. Magnitsky and who's mr.
Browder the Latin America born UK hedge
fund manager had a huge business in
Moscow in the 90s and early 2000s Russia
believes not very clean he was charged
with nine years in prison in absentia
for tax fraud Sergei Magnitsky was his
lawyer and top tax adviser and obviously
Russia considered him to be involved in
mr. brower's criminal activity and he
was arrested and died in a pretrial
detention under controversial
circumstances William Browder known for
his decade-long campaign against Russian
corruption accused Russia of killing
Magnitsky who had testified against the
country's tax authorities and police he
used this case to lobby the so-called
Magnitsky Act sanctioning Russian
officials implicated in corruption and
now prosecuted general office here in
Moscow is practically pushing forward
mirror accusations saying that the death
of Sergei Magnitsky was in fact in the
interest of William Browder covering his
dirty financial schemes and adding that
they are opening an investigation into
that it has been in the news for years
that Russia is accusing William Browder
of money laundering and embezzlement
and now prosecutor-general office opened
a criminal case into organizing a
transnational criminal network for these
purposes let's take a listen for a long
time Russia's prosecutor general
together with the investigative
authorities have been seeking to
prosecute William Browder and other
members of an international criminal
network organized and led by him this
network was created in Russia in 1997
and continues to operate today it aims
to carry out serious economic crimes
both on Russian territory and abroad
this is a very serious crime here in
Russia if guilty mr. browser may face up
to 20 years in prison
prosecutor general office has also said
that Russia will soon hask for mr.
Browdy to be extradited since this type
of crimes covers by the UN Convention it
was also added that some time ago a huge
file about mr. brother's crimes about a
thousand long document had been handed
over to US authorities but Russia never
received any answer it would be fair to
mention that mr. Browdy himself believes
that all this is politically motivated
he reiterated many times that Putin
personally stopped him
you